as machines become increasingly
autonomous by which I mean that they can
sense their environment and they can
make decisions about what to do or what
not to do of course it's based on their
programming and their experience but we
don't have this direct control over what
they do as we do today with the kinds of
technology that we have now there's a
couple of very interesting consequences
of that one of them is that they're
going to be faced with having to make
ethical decisions I'll call it ethics
jr. is just making socially appropriate
decisions so we're taking machines and
we're putting them in situations where
they're around people and something that
we take for granted and it seems so
natural that machines do not take for
granted and do not find natural is the
normal kinds of social courtesies and
conventions that we operate by in
dealing with other people you don't want
to have a robot that's making a delivery
or run down the sidewalk and you know
everybody's got to get out of the way it
has to be able to walk in a crowd in a
socially appropriate way your autonomous
car there are lots of very interesting
ethical conundrums that come up but a
lot of them are just social ok it pulls
up to discuss the crosswalk should you
cross should you wait how's it going to
signal you it's right now the social
dimensions you make eye contact with the
driver and they tell you whether to
cross you know now I can't make eye
contact with an autonomous car so there
are lots of these sort of rough edges
around how machines ought to be able to
behave and the situation's are highly
variable you can't just make a list of
them and say do this and do that we need
to program into these devices some
fairly general principles you can call
them ethical if you like which will
allow them to guide their own behavior
in ways and interactions that are
consistent with the expectations that we
have in society now I'm I'm teaching at
Stanford and I can tell you I haven't
seen anything about this in the
engineering curriculum there's how to be
an ethical engineer but there isn't how
do you build a device to be ethical this
is a completely new area that's
sometimes got some name moral
programming computational ethics
there's some excellent books on this
subject but unfortunately if you read
those books which I I have to do because
that's my my job they're mostly pointing
out the problems nobody has a really
good scheme for how to go about doing
this
so we need to develop an engineering
discipline of computational ethics and
we need to have course sequences in our
engineering schools that teach how to
get machines to behave appropriately in
a wide variety of new circumstances
let me point out some of the more
serious kinds of conundrums just to give
you a feel for it and then others that
are just inconveniences okay on the very
serious side there's a classic
philosophical debate that goes on over
what's called the trolley problem and
the trolley problem is basically you're
you're in a trolley and there's track
splits if you take no action the trolley
is going to go to the right and there
are four people on the track and it's
going to kill those people you can flip
a switch and it'll go down the left
track and there's only one person on
that track the ethical question is is it
ethical to flip that switch it is true
that the loss of life would be minimized
but is also true that you've now taken
an action to kill somebody and if you're
that person you may not think that's the
right the right thing to do so
philosophers have been studying this and
many variations and there's a lot of
very subtle and interesting work that
goes on in this but this is about to
become very real because autonomous cars
will face exactly these kinds of
decisions so I'm gonna buy an autonomous
car and I'm in the car I'm the one guy
and there may be circumstances in which
there are four lives four people in
front of the car in some way and to save
their lives my car has to drive off the
edge of the bridge there's a
philosophical Theory called
utilitarianism which has been around for
a couple of centuries at least that
would say that maximizing the good for
society is my car should kill me if I'm
not buying that car and so we have a
conundrum here I don't want to see
people buying a Ford instead of a Chevy
because des Ford's more likely to save
my life no matter what and the Chevy is
going to be a little more forgiving of
of that and and might kill me too to
save the lives of other people I don't
want that to be a selling point in cars
so we need to have a societal discussion
over how does this work
to demonstrate why that is so
interesting I'll just give it a twist on
what I said
right now we're talking about me buying
an autonomous car but let's suppose I'm
signed up for the great uber network in
the sky of the future and cars are
coming and whatever and it I don't own
that car now I feel a little bit
differently about it because it's not my
car I'm just like I'm getting on a train
we would never allow a train to the
people on the train to vote you know
like you know okay I love my car killed
and not you know to kill me and not that
one they're certain then it makes more
sense for the societal average interests
to to be operational so when I think
about this issue even the fact of who
owns the car changes my own moral
judgement about this particular kind of
an issue well we need to be able to take
these kinds of principles talk about
them vet them and put them into cars so
autonomous driving cars it's got I've
got a number of different issues that
are very very important now I've so far
I've just talked about life and death
but there's lots of shades of grey in
between that are really quite quite
different in fact I'm gonna make an
argument to you today that we're already
down this path and we haven't even
recognized yet for a very interesting
reason because in order to avoid
pointing out this problem the car
manufacturers do not talk about this as
artificial intelligence let me give you
an example a common function cars is ABS
DAC adaptive braking systems I think
it's what that stands for and what that
will do is if it can detect which it can
that you're about to skid it's going to
pump the brakes and to various things to
maintain control of the car and keep it
going in a particular direction okay now
what you might not know
is that abs in many cases on certain
surfaces has a longer stopping distance
then if you just jammed on the brakes
locked them in the car spun around so
imagine you're driving your car and oh
my god there's a kid in the middle of
the road and you you just want that car
to stop as quickly as it possible as you
can and you you slam on the brakes well
the car is going to prioritize keeping
going straight over running over that
kid in today's technology there are
circumstances in which that decision
which an engineer made a while back in
designing that system what I want to
keep the car stable you no longer have
the freedom to make the decision I don't
mind if the car spins out of control as
long as I miss that kid so now imagine
that the ABS function had been described
as we're simulating the actions of a
professional driver and we're taking
that judgment and we're programming it
to a machine using these advanced
artificial intelligence techniques so
that the car can keep under control the
same way a professional driver might
well we might have fell a little bit
differently about that if I presented
you with that example and we were
talking about this as an AI technology
but by saying it's simply a function of
the car and it's just like it's like
every other phone you know it's like the
turn signals and everything else this
issue never really got raised and never
really got vetted but as we look to the
future of autonomous driving it's going
to be a problem let me move on there too
less less severe situations you're in
your autonomous car and it pulls you're
on a two-lane Street this happens all
the time there's a UPS truck right in
front of you see if it's come to a stop
the guy jumps out he opens up the back
he grabs a package that starts hitting
off now you as a driver are permitted a
certain amount of latitude in how you
behave and what we what would you do you
look around it
you'd go across the double yellow line
and you pass that UPS truck it's
perfectly acceptable behavior may I
point out you're breaking a rule you're
crossing a double yellow line if we were
to program our cars simply to say
you're never supposed to cross the
double yellow line that cars gonna sit
there until the guy's done which might
be a very long time if he's gone to his
lunch so the kinds of latitude that we
permit people in their behavior in a lot
of these circumstances to be able to
break rules or bend rules in a very
appropriate way we need to talk about
whether or not it's okay for a car to
engage in that kind of behavior let me
give you another one what would you feel
if you went down the movie theater and
you're the scarcity it's available all
of a sudden you find this sixteen robots
in line in front of you and you're at
the back of the line
my reaction be hey wait a minute that's
not fair why do we have sixteen robots
that are gonna pick up tickets for
whoever owns the robots I'm here you
know we should prioritize me over those
robots I think when that begins to
happen in practice people will be up in
arms because they can see what is
actually happening but that same
situation is already happening today if
you try to get a ticket to Billy Joel at
Madison Square Garden scalpers run
programs that can snap up all of those
tickets in a matter of seconds leaving
all the humans who are sitting there
trying to press the The Return button or
god forbid fill out the little CAPTCHA
there they don't get the stuff so it's
exactly the same situation
the robots are who are owned and working
for somebody else are grabbing an asset
before you have an opportunity or a fair
chance to acquire that asset to get that
particular ticket you know and if you
could see that people be really mad
today but it's invisible because all
this stuff is in the cloud so we're
already facing a lot of these same
ethical and social issues but they're
they're not as visible as they need to
be for us to have a meaningful public
discussion about these particular topics